could be
is we're talking about a little bit
earlier quibby's like a competitor of
uh uh if you want to put that article up
kai that'd be great for us to look at
the quibby article
so they come out and they say they're
going to compete
with netflix with hulu with all of these
guys
and their platform is to show
10-minute films on your phone because
they believe the younger audience
is going to watch movies more on their
phone right so that's what they do
the the founder is katzenberg who
katzenberg if you know what katzenberg
he's got a ridiculous resume
910 million dollar guy and he brings in
meg whitman you know meg whitman she ran
for republican
governor in the state of california i
think she spent 150 million dollars to
win she almost did but she lost it
5.1 billion billion a person who took
ebay from 8 million to 32 billion
so they had a start i mean great lineup
they had at quibby right so they have
the funding
investors sony nbc warner time warner
goldman sachs jp morgan alibaba
i mean the list is a long list of people
that came in and said
stars galore stars galore the rock kevin
hart lebron james
j.lo uh you name it the list goes on oh
they had everybody so pat
what happened with this group they had
all this backing they had
all this star power they had all the
influence yeah six
six months old gum what happened 1.8
billion by the way if you think this
we're not
a lot of money right we're not a little
bit of money it's a lot of money we're
talking about
1.8 billion so what really happened
here's here's a couple things
if you read their quote i don't know if
you have the quote up or not when they
went out of business
the way katzenberg put it that they went
out of business he just said it very
simply
you know uh we believe that this didn't
oh there it is and wednesday letter mr
katzenberg and ms whitman
said there were one or two reasons for
kubi's failure the idea behind could be
either wasn't strong enough to justify
stand-alone streaming service
or the services launch in the middle of
a pandemic was particularly
ill-timed so they're saying what either
we had a bad idea
or it's because of pandemic right more
likely the former meaning the pandemic
so you think no
no he's saying a bad idea bad idea that
idea is a bad idea okay so bad idea is a
bad idea
okay so let's go with both
let's go with both okay let's go first
two questions with that let's go first
with bad idea let's say it's a bad idea
okay
so so what's a bad idea a bad idea is
that people don't want to watch content
short
films you know 10 minutes they don't
want to be entertained by that
i don't think it's a bad idea is it
pandemic you know is it the fact that
they came out at a bad time i mean
tiger king joe exotic for a week was the
most famous person in the world
because his you know documentary his
video was watched
sixth the last dance came out in march
april is the biggest thing
there's been no throttling of your
ability to get on your your mobile
device so
that way the pandemic yeah was affecting
this and i'm glad you were saying that
yeah i mean no question about that but i
i do believe that
a lot of people that are successful once
you reach some modicum of success you
begin to think you know what people want
and that's when it gets dangerous
because you have to let the people tell
you what they want
and this was the classic case of
throwing a lot of money at something
they were you know they got themselves
up and lathered up about it i remind
myself constantly
in our marketing hey we think this one's
going to work we're testing some web
pages right now
i said look before we test them let's
have everybody vote on it so we can show
that you know there's going to be
differing opinions at the end of the day
the consumer decides which one they like
better
and apparently this just didn't resonate
yeah yeah i mean
you know that's one of the things that
they talk about but the other part of is
when you when they talk about quibby is
the fact that
so here's our audience they want 18 to
34 year old audience who they're going
after we want customers that are 18 to
34 right
yet they go get a-listers and pay them a
hundred thousand dollars a minute to
advertise
they don't own any of their content very
little of their content they own it's
purely a technology company that they
sell themselves as
meaning we are a tech company we're not
necessarily a netflix
content creation company because what
they had was
when you put the video there and you're
watching it you spin it it was a real
nice
integration how smooth it was on so
people loved it and then
rather than going after these big
youtubers like a mr beast who's got 45
million subscribers to bring a guy like
that and say hey
you know why don't you come and join us
and you know give them some equity or do
partnership with guys like that
they went with the traditional a-listers
is where they went after
and the next thing you know 1.8 billion
in six months and here's the other part
why are you shutting down after six
months like how do you know this thing's
not going to work out
you know how many changes netflix had to
make remember back in the days you got
the discs from net
they would just send you the dvd and you
send them back they send you another one
and another one and another one
how like old does that feel at this
point but what i'm trying to tell you is
they recreated themselves multiple times
and quibby's just like
nope we're done so they're giving 350
million dollars back to their investors
and they're shutting you down
so you must have a strong opinion as to
what the hell happened here because in
my opinion
i don't think they had a bad idea that
was a that's that was the former yeah
and and launching anything digital
on your phone while people are sitting
at home during a pandemic
can't be a bad idea right is it too much
competition in the marketplace is it a
best business model
what do you think actually happened with
this group did they put too much money
into these a-listers
and not to the c-listers who they could
have got cheaper what the hell happened
if you're going after 18 to 34 year olds
why don't you go get the 18 to 34 year
old's audience get some tick tockers on
what are you doing getting the 47 year
olds and the 50 year olds the 18 to 34
year olds
followed that tick tockers that's got 15
million followers that you and i have no
clue who she is
go get her 18 to 34 year olds follow the
instagram girl lord guy that's got
22 million followers that you and i may
not know about go get him or her
right go get the youtuber that's got 29
million subscribers
do you have you ever watched mr beast i
did i have
which one have you watched it mr beast
he gave away like cars the other day
okay
he just gives away cars like it's
raining perfect he gives away cars
okay or what's the other guy's name the
other guy named uh
david he's the guy with the borat is
that who the borah guys
you want to play the video what this guy
just did here's how they just launched
borat together oh that was awesome david
dobrik
yeah this is how they launched borat's
movie
it's got 8.5 million views okay these
are young
marketing geniuses okay they could have
gone to guys like this because these are
the audience they have the audience
you want click on it to see what these
guys
are looking to bring you guys here today
i introduce you guys to one of my
friends
he flew in all the way from kazakhstan
hello
oh my god oh my god
back it up back it up back it up
back it up [ __ ]
[Applause]
150 000 card they hit eight and a half
million views okay that eight and a half
million views already paid for the door
that's six that was six and a half
million on saturday that was six and a
half million on saturday
you're making somewhere between 10 or 15
grand per million views
so you figure what's what's that right
there so 80 to 120
000 was paid by that video just to do an
integration borat got plenty of
marketing for his movie this is genius
did he
do what he says about the price of the
car yeah keep playing keep playing it
kai
it's not cheap it's expensive no this is
an expensive car
yeah look how
the guy is ridiculous how capable he is
he's ridiculous how capable
but the point is you know he i think
half the battle with quibby
adam if you ask me is they throw in the
towel too early
they throw in the towel too early they
listen to the wrong people there was
this article written about it that they
said if you went to the quirby
headquarters it was so cocky so arrogant
it was like
you know everything about them was that
they're better than everybody else and
they're going to take over the
marketplace and there wasn't
a cool feeling about them there was this
we're above everybody we're going like
they already made it it was that kind of
a feeling that they had at their
headquarters
we've already made it like sexy
headquarters that already set up spent a
lot of money on it
so you know again for me the biggest
thing with could be if you think about
it is
they simply threw in the towel way too
early when we started the business like
i started the business
we had to change a million times we
tested a million different things that
didn't work until
boom something clicked i think it's too
early and they could have competed
uh with the marketplace i uh uh i wish
it would have stuck around a little
longer
yeah i talked to my son about this all
the time and as it relates to he's in
the music business
and uh in the old days back when we were
kids
uh a record label would sign an artist
that had some talent
and then they would promote that they'd
get it played on
radio all that paola stuff and you
didn't have any
the audience didn't decide what the hits
were the record labels decided what was
going to be popular
and that's how it worked and today it
doesn't work that way the record labels
just can't force content down anybody
and people can go out and become popular
without
the the assistance of all that promotion
because
it's it's much more organic and if you
get cocky and you think you can actually
jam
stuff down people's throats it doesn't
work that way this it's much more
transparent it's much more real
today and so they obviously missed and
you said they gave back 350 million
dollars to the investors so
apparently there was a lot of people in
on that decision to say you know what
we're going in the wrong direction we
don't want to waste the last 350 and
we're not sure we're going to be able to
raise more if we lose 1.8 billion
and so you know who is who are we i mean
we don't we're not inside their
boardroom we don't have all the facts
they have
we can speculate there is one thing that
we can't speculate there's a big
lawsuit going on right now with them uh
what was that one company that's
echo echo ecko some name like that
they were the ones that made the
technology that would go smooth yeah
and so they presented that technology to
them with katzenberg in the room
and they went ahead and did it
themselves and echo the company that's
suing them
uh uh uh is echo they're eko
they're a very well-funded company with
powerful names so if they sue you
that's not a small lawsuit they're
coming after you to to get exactly what
they want
so some are saying that could be that
reason but they just kind of don't want
to go play ball because
the lawsuit can make it really ugly
you're right we don't know about it and
we're speculating but that's why we have
a podcast we sit here speculating about
everybody's lives
pat would you unpack something for me we
obviously know if this if this company
would have been
successful it would have started to make
money and generate revenue awesome
awesome awesome
what happens on the flip side a company
doesn't work would you you guys are both
founders ceos of your companies
what happens when in the boardroom when
they guys we're going to have to shut
down we're going to have to do this
we're going to have to
give money back to investors walk me
through that conversation i haven't had
that conversation
well good that's a good thing but but
imagine if you did like
how does that conversation sound like
like what happens to this you raise
1.8 billion you don't control 51
the company when you don't control 51
the company there you don't make the
decision it's a vote
so there is no one person one person in
the room could have been like no i think
we can make this work and the other
three are voting against you it doesn't
matter what you think
okay it's a different environment
because you went and raised 1.8 billion
what do you own who has the same way
what do you think when you raise 1.8
billion now the money people tell you
what to do and
anytime money people are telling you
what to do they're not in the business
they're not hitting on a daily basis to
know what's going on who's working who's
not working
who's excited who's not excited you
don't see any of that stuff so
it's a different it's a big difference
between that and having a small business
owner
that goes and raises his own money with
a half a million dollars they start a
business they control 100
of it eventually they give up 5 10 15 20
and they can still make that decision
themselves
not in a situation like this these are
venture capitalists angel investors who
are these people that are making
these guys are not angel investors there
is no angel in there
probably no angels in there these are
people that have money these are people
that are coming and saying i'll give you
a hundred million i'll give you 50
million
big bets but i've talked to small
business owners that have raised and
given up even five ten fifteen twenty
percent
and i said why do you worry about what
the investors think when you have eighty
percent you say you don't understand
they have hooks they have
they have things where they can they can
just get they can muck up the works
and they can get in the way even though
they don't have control so it's not like
hey just keep 51
and you call all the shots doesn't work
that way you're right
but there's an element of it well i tell
you for myself i'm the majority owner
where i'm at right
but i agreed to the certain uh hooks
that they put in right certain awarding
that they put in where
hey anytime you're going to spend
anything about 500 000 check on one
thing call us
okay so if i'm if i'm going to do
something at an event then it's going to
cost me 3 million
i got to call them if i'm investing into
a technology it's going to cost me 25
million
i got to call them on anything about a
half a million dollars because we're
dealing with their 10 million dollars
right so you got to go and
get the approval there but for the most
part if you get the right money people
they'll leave you alone
if you're grown we've grown 50 every
year for god knows how many years now so
to them they're like listen keep doing
what you're doing monthly card that we
do we're good to go quarterly
call that we have and we get together
we're good to go so as long as you're
bringing in return
right they don't bother in this case
they didn't in this case
they got 930 000 initial free
subscribers that they did
okay here's a number i think it's 910
000 subscribers
right off the bat quibby app was number
three the day it came out it was the
number three most downloaded after they
came out
after a couple weeks it's not even the
top 50. do you know how to that 910
thousand how many of them subscribe
to 4.99 a month with could be a month
later do you know how many of them
93 dropped off only 72 000 subscribe
only 72 they're like nah i'm not in it
72 000 said i'm in the other 9 800 some
thousand they said i'm out so
there is there is there is an element of
fatigue in terms of hey i've got netflix
i've got yeah i've got all these like
hulu there's so much [ __ ] but guys i
disagree i totally disagree and this is
why this is good to have this kind of a
podcast
i disagree here's why i disagree do you
have netflix i do
when did you buy oh man i can't long
time ago over 10 years ago what caused
you to get netflix
uh they just had the service i wanted i
mean it was perfect but why why did you
get it was there a show that
you hooked you in can you remember cause
amber do you have netflix no
not anymore no actually i i was actually
on the original
with the cds and whatever you were on
what i wanted to do was i wanted to have
these movies available to me so i i'd
get the cd
i'd burn it down yeah i'd have it with
me when i when i was traveling i'd put
it on my laptop
and and i could watch a movie on my
laptop and i i'd get them i'd
i'd burn them i'd send them back
whatever whether that was legal or not
legal i don't know
and uh at the end of the day i ended up
just sort of morphing into their
their streaming platform how about
yourself and i do remember their very
very first
the first i don't know if you know this
the first original content you know what
it was on netflix house of cards
no what's what's the original content
lilly hammer
did you see lily hammer no any of you
guys seen lily hammer
sopranos you sopranos guy no
no if you're not a sopranos guy so
but there you go that's a perfect
example lily hummer
got you well i mean it certainly was wow
these people are serious they must have
got the people that are
creating original content on hbo or
whatever are you on netflix
so i had netflix but now i canceled it
but here's my point with the whole you
say that
you don't think it's a competition thing
no it has to be at least some percentage
of competition sure
why is it a competition thing i'll tell
you why do you have amazon prime
i don't know do you have amazon i got
amazon for one
i don't you have disney plus i don't
okay you have
youtube tv no hbo max no
sling tv crunchyroll apple tv
twitch sony crackle the list goes on and
on and on i can keep going
so yes there there are some obviously
some issues with their business model
yeah for sure
this is a perfect time for the legendary
question what's your point
your point is you're saying that it's
not competition yeah
in in my opinion there has to be some
element of competition
because you can't have 12 different
things on your uh that you're going to
be watching listen
for me how many okay let's just finalize
this how many do you have
you have netflix you have amazon prime
you've got disney plus for your kids
okay what else do you have but but think
about everything you're saying right
there yeah why do i have them
the question isn't if i have them or not
why do i have them you have them because
you want them
do you know why i have amazon do you
know why i have amazon
why i have amazon you know why i have
amazon yeah why because you watched you
wanted to watch shiloh buff's movie
honeyboy i wanted to watch honeyboy i'm
a die-hard shy label fan
okay so honeyboy is a story about him
and his father so i wanted to watch shia
labeouf he makes this movie
about his life with his father any
in a sit down with jimmy kimmel says i
made this movie
to uh uh be by my father and i had my
dad i said dad please watch this movie
he had his dad watch the movie with one
uh uh uh
agreement that he made with his dad i
want to watch you on facetime
you watch the movie i just want to see
your facial reactions so he makes the
movie all these scenes about his dad
and he watches his dad's reaction the
entire time you know what i do i go by
amazon i haven't canceled this since
i've never watched anything else
except for honeyboy just because of shia
labeouf i got netflix because of house
of cards
i have disney plus because of kids i
don't have hulu because no show's got me
on hulu yet
and so the point i'm trying to make to
you is
i agree there's a lot of competition
don't forget google is a number 14
search engine ever to come out
that means before google there was 13
others so what do you mean there's
company of course there's going to be
competition
amazon came out while there was millions
of sears costco
you know sam's club you know kmart all
this
and then amazon comes and they're
killing everybody with the
company for a while though but that's
from 94. the point is the point is
they didn't throw in the towel i think
in a situation like this there's one
part about what he said that i agree
with one part what he said that i agree
was the first comment you made
and the comment was sometimes when you
win you think you're winning everything
and you can't just because you were a
great basketball player your name is
michael jordan doesn't mean you're going
to be a great owner
just because you were a great basketball
player magic johnson doesn't mean you're
going to make a good cause i thought you
were going somewhere totally
especially when it when it comes to
trying to anticipate what consumers are
going to do and how they're going to
react to your product okay you just
don't know you think you know
the more success you have the more you
think you know um
and how many of you here that are
watching this
how many here that are watching this
actually subscribe to quibby i'll be so
curious how many of you that are
watching this right now
actually subscribe to quibby comment
below if you actually subscribe to
courtney i'm gonna give you the craziest
stat here
the craziest at they advertised during
oscars
and they advertised during super bowl
they did a five and a half million
dollar commercial during super bowl for
quibby
afterwards 70 of responders when they
did their review on quibby you know what
they thought quibby was
they thought it was a food delivery
[Laughter]
[Music]
service